tell them if you were a robot and I knew
and you didn't want me to tell you that
depends when I learned that I'm a robot
will I be able to handle it maybe
although the history of science fiction
is not on your side what the gang from
the Big Bang Theory considers science
fiction is reality for researchers at
MIT this week they unveiled a robot
capable of playing the game
Jenga it's an automated system that has
had a learning period first and it uses
the information of both of the camera
and the force torque sensor to interpret
the the interactions with the Jenga
tower the industrial robotic arm can
view the Jenga tower and using
artificial intelligence determine which
pieces are best suited to move while the
robot is playing a game researchers say
its ability has more important real
world applications imagine an on simply
line many of the tasks involved in
assembling a let's say cell phone
required tactile cues right required
detecting whether a snap feed is that
correct snap or not doesn't come from
visual information but rather from force
information
I smell robot but there's no reason to
worry about being completely replaced by
a robot in games like chess or go we can
get robots to play at superhuman
performance but at games like Jenga
which anyone can play robots are still
far below the level that humans can can
do
that's somewhat comforting right yeah
you know I feel about robots